good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have a special ability to create
something amazing that can change the
planet so to help you in your journey
today we're going to learn about how to
overcome guilt and shame
rule number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best
[Music]
but living guilty doesn't do anything
productive it doesn't help you to do
better it causes you to struggle more
guilt drains you emotionally physically
it will wear you out when we're guilty
we don't pursue dreams we don't believe
to overcome challenges we get stuck this
is why the enemy works overtime in this
area he knows guilt will keep you from
your destiny there's nothing he would
love any more than for you to go through
life against yourself focused on your
failures feeling unworthy shame is far
more likely to cause destructive
behaviors than it is to cure it what we
know is that shame is highly correlated
with addiction violence aggression
bullying it's not helpful to be ashamed
for this reason and I think this is
really a core thing that we need to get
our heads and hearts around as a culture
shame corrodes the part of us that
believes we can change so to change
someone into changing is like saying to
them you are horrible and worthless and
you're not capable of change
get better
the best way to deal with shame for
people is to find what you're most proud
of you can't
you're never gonna deal with shame you
have to overwhelm it with the good it's
kind of like if every day of your life
you look around you let it happen news
comes in and it's almost always these
days something to scare you if it glides
it leads they stay in the newspaper
business so something to jar you if
you're gonna have your life you have to
like all snap the good
you have to flood yourself with the good
you have to say what am i proud of in my
life what am i grateful for and you got
to literally think of three or four or
five things people experiences it could
be something little you're proud of when
you're a kid something today but if you
do what I call an emotional flood we
flood yourself with all the beautiful
proud things things you're grateful for
in your life you'll find that'll
overwhelm that feeling of shame and the
shame feeling will disappear but it
won't disappear by analyzing it right
right right
then you use good morning so a lot of
people confuse guilt with shame you said
they're cousins I say they're cousins
kissing cousins shame says there's
something wrong with Who I am
its intrinsic I can't do anything about
it guilt says there's something wrong
with what I've done or am doing or am
doing yeah this or I feel guilty about
that even people now feel guilty about
what they think you know what they say
both of them
well shame is is a little deeper guilt
however is a wasted emotion yeah that's
what I said it's a wasted emotion
because the minute you find that there's
something wrong or out of alignment
you're out of order and what you're
thinking of doing do something else when
we know we call cause hurt harm danger
to someone yeah that will lead us guilt
we look at what we did and how it hurts
us shouldn't you feel guilty about that
well no I think you can make amends okay
and you can do better next time what
does guilt serve it doesn't serve
anything other than the ego okay which
is to take you out of the acknowledgment
that you call cause hurt harm or danger
Elizabeth a knowledge about you you
cause that to somebody it's not the same
thing as feeling guilty about it no
knowledge it ask for forgiveness of
yourself first and then of other people
if you can and if you can do something
to make amends yes then that will
release release you from the
karmak tied to that action I have
interviewed over 600 million women now
across the country about shame and
across the interviews men and women with
high levels of resilience to shame share
four things in common the first is they
physically recognize when they're in
shame and they know what triggered it so
let's say something happens at work I
make a mistake or something happens and
that warm wash comes over me you know
that feeling yeah if I can physically
say oh my god this is shame I'm in shame
it's very helpful because we are not fit
for human consumption when we're in
shame we need to pull away and get re
grounded take some deep breaths and
figure out how to respond one of the
things that makes a m-- worse is
normally when we're in it we act out for
example the mother that I interviewed
she fills her car up she goes into the
gas station she goes to pay her credit
cards declined the man shane's her in
front of the other patrons makes her
leave her I think her wedding band and
her wallet and lead with just an ATM
card so she's filled with shame she gets
in the car she slams the door when she
slams the door it wakes up her
three-year-old toddler who's in the
backseat who starts screaming what
happens next
she starts screaming back shut up shut
up so now she's in the shame of having
this credit card decline
being belittled in front of people and
now having to deal with the you know the
struggle of on the horrible mom and why
am i taking this out of my child so men
and women with high levels of resilience
recognize physically when they're in
shame and what triggered it
okay then they practice critical
awareness how realistic are the
expectations and messages that we put on
ourselves through that others put on us
that tell us who we're supposed to be
the third thing is men and women with
high levels of resilience reach out
we've got to share our story so they
talk about it they talk about it
you know we breathe through it we
recognize we're in it and then we call
and say hey Patricia it's me you're not
gonna believe what happened can you
listen it's it's hard and then we speak
shame you know it's I try to explain to
people the importance of using the word
shame
and this is not just laypeople this is
mental health professionals right you
know we've got to use the word it's
different if I were to call you into a
Patricia I am so embarrassed that would
be one thing right but if I were to call
you and say Patricia it's Brennan I'm
really struggling with some shame that's
different it's a different conversation
right shame cannot hold on when we name
it right so it's not just you know an
academic pet peeve I want everybody to
get the semantics correct men and women
with high levels of shame resilience use
the word and talk about the emotion
someone wrote in saying that they wake
up in the middle of the night saying I
shouldn't have done that they feel
guilty about eating that whole chocolate
cake they feel really bad about certain
career choices about certain clothes
choices food choices
what are those kind of choices right and
they are now turning on themselves they
say it's easy to forgive other people
but when it comes to themselves they
have a really hard time what should they
do what's helped me along my journey is
if I could turn back the hands of time
right if I could turn back the hands of
time ask yourself would I change my path
I'll give you five seconds to answer
okay that's great
so you said yes you said yes you would
change your path
okay let me ask you this if I could take
away all the lessons learned from your
past would you allow me to five seconds
okay great you said no so you want the
lessons but you don't want the
experiences oh boy can I get a Hello
okay okay
okay this is what's helped me to realize
there are lessons learned right
everything happens for a reason the next
person that tells me that
what happens when people say that
sometimes it feels really cringe-worthy
right really cringe-worthy right do you
know what happened to me in my puss
everything happens for a reason
can I get a hello there no it really
doesn't have to it really doesn't have
to be like that right that's what we
tell ourselves when I realize lessons
learned was about not judging our past
right when you don't judge your past
it's a lot easier to accept what has
taken place we are in disbelief I can't
believe it happened I can't believe I
got a scratch on that new car on the
first day in the first hour when I was
listening to less party can I get a
Hello they're not my favorite son for
goodness sakes it could have been the
other crap one but yeah sometimes your
house gets robbed on your birthday
sometimes you buy a new dress and then
you trip up and mud goes everywhere and
now you feel like it shouldn't have
happened but it did
in dealing with self forgiveness which
really is the gateway the passage to
becoming your greatest version
you got a mousse saying it shouldn't
have happened
instead say it did happen and I'm gonna
change how I respond to what happened
it's hard to defend yourself when the
murmuring of the voice of accusation is
stronger on the inside
did the voice of all the critics on the
outside guilt is not just about what
others are saying about you it is what
you are saying about yourself it is it
is the condemnation that comes upon you
it is a struggle that lives down inside
of you that you say have you ever said
what was that
thinking have you ever looked back in
time and you just wonder what if what
was I on to do that what what happened
dinner dinner you know there's somebody
put something in my coke what happened
that I went that far you may not see
this is this one of the things that we
do with guilt because it is such a heavy
burden to carry
it's it's a heavy burden because it can
only exist in places where you care it
can only exists in places where you care
so it becomes a heavy burden to carry so
what we do is we change the narrative of
what happened to make the memory more
palatable we change the narrative of
what happened to make the memory more
palatable we block out the parts we are
saying dove and we remember how people
responded to us without remembering how
we elicited or initiated the response
selective amnesia and tell you all what
happened until you take responsibility
for it until you until you stop hiding
from the guilt see because you're trying
to tranquilize the kill you you know why
your daughter
disrespected you you know why she cursed
you out you know what she saw about you
in the neighbor across the street but
you blocked out what happens between you
and the neighbor across the street and
talk about angle let that girl
disrespect me she just lost her man when
in reality you oh you told me to go deep
you told me to go deep you know think
about them haters I'm not a hater I'm
hurt
cuz you beat me like a dog and I'm
telling the truth that's not a hater
but you changed the story because the
weight of the matter might mean you
admitting my son is acting crazy because
I wasn't a good father and I really
wasn't there for him and he saw things
out of me that I wish I hadn't had done
but at that stage in my life I did it
you have to stop telling these I don't
know water boy crazy you do you doing
know why he's acting crazy and you're
the only one who can fix it because you
do know what's wrong with him and you
can't you can't get he'll brother as
long as you tell you the worth of I got
it away where it's not my fault
he couldn't you know what the problem is
but the weight the weight of the guilt
you know that you cannot heal it
if you won't own it are you angry about
something you could fix guilt that leads
to a change of behavior it's a powerful
thing
guilt and crabs who by the through them
makes you call me on the phone and say
look I'm sorry
is a powerful thing it's a wonderful
thing for you to be guilty enough to
humble yourself to pull your pride down
it pull your images down and pull all
the lies you told to yourself down and
say look I miss you and I'm tired of us
fighting like this and whatever I did to
hurt you I'm sorry I'm man enough to
look you in the eye and say I was wrong
and I'm sorry be healed
[Applause]
you can fix thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what was the rule
that most applies to you that you're
going to immediately implement somehow
into your life or your business please
let me know I'd love to hear from you
leave it down in the comments below I
also want to give a quick charta to
Clark Kegley Clark thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the interview on your
channel I really really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the vodka how do you find your passion
make money doing what you love and stand
out in an ever-growing noisy world you
distill everything down into one word so
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love as you soon